polonia no tendrá acceso a los dineros
del fondo de recuperación post pandemia
así lo advirtió úrsula fonda legend en
el debate de la eurocámara en el que se
analizaba la decisión del tribunal
constitucional de polonia que dictaminó
que algunas leyes europeas van en contra
de la constitución polaca o no de
members
señorías no podemos ni permitiremos que
se pongan en peligro nuestros valores
comunes la comisión actuará y todas las
opciones son conocidas ante options own
the political and just weeks plane el
gobierno polaco tiene que explicarnos
cómo pretende proteger el dinero europeo
dada esta sentencia de su tribunal
constitucional idea constitucional watch
el enfrentamiento amplificó las
tensiones entre el bloque europeo y
polonia bruselas ha expresado su
preocupación sobre las normas polacas
que recibe como un retraso en la
democracia incluida la prohibición en
enero del derecho de las mujeres a
abortar en casos de malformación del
feto haciendo que polonia tenga la ley
más restrictiva en europa con respecto a
la interrupción del embarazo así como la
declaración de varias regiones como
zonas libres de ideología el eje bético
plus
polonia le respondió a bruselas que no
se dejará chantajear
con este objetivo es que habló en este
debate para presentarles el tema
práctico de la controversia y no para
continuar difundiendo historias
informaciones políticas sobre política
sobre el tema de un retroceso del estado
de derecho
2 sin embargo a diferencia del reino
unido antes de su referéndum break si en
2016 en polonia el apoyo popular a la
pertenencia a la unión europea sigue
siendo alto por el momento no hay un
pool éxito a la vista